our next speaker
coming from out there
is
Cynthia
okay I guess it shouldn't take more time
please go ahead
okay thank you very much
Tony happy birthday and I'm absolutely
delighted to be part of this and honored
to be so early in the schedule so this
talk is going to be uh as narrow as
Russell's talk was brought
and um
um
I'll just start so in case you don't
know uh differential privacy is a
definition of privacy tailored to the
statistical analysis of large data sets
and it says roughly speaking that the
outcome of any analysis is essentially
equally likely independent of whether
any individual joins or refrains from
joining the data set and there's an
equation that captures this which is
that if we have two data sets X and Y
that differ in the data of just one
person and we have a mechanism M that is
going to give us differential privacy
with parameter Epsilon then for any
possible event s the probability that we
observe s when the database is X is at
most e to the Epsilon times the
probability that we observe s when the
data set is y
okay
so most of the work on differential
privacy for a long time uh
was in the setting in which there was a
static data set and all of the data were
collected in one place and there was a a
curator who runs the algorithms and does
all the right Randomness and releases
results
and together with Tony we started
looking at the case of dynamic data
about 2008 2009 and papers came out
about a year later and there were sort
of three issues that would come up alone
or in combination so here I have
pictured a data stream you can think of
a data stream in which data of an
individual can appear multiple times for
example we might have a stream of search
queries and I might make two or three
searches
um or maybe a stream of movies watched
on Netflix by different people and a
given individual might appear multiple
times maybe the yellow user here watched
three movies in this
and um in user level privacy we want to
protect all instances simultaneously of
a user's participation like all movie
watching by this person and in what we
call event level privacy we want just to
protect the privacy of any individual
event so in other words with user level
privacy we would be protecting your
sustained love of Mickey Mouse movies
versus in event level privacy we would
be uh protecting the fact that you
viewed one Mickey Mouse movie last night
so that was the first issue the second
issue
had to do with trying to prevent Mission
creep
um with data and protect against
warrants and subpoenas so we introduced
a notion called pan privacy where what
we want to keep we want privacy over the
joint distribution not just on the
outputs that are
uh produced by the algorithm but also on
the algorithms internal state so the
algorithm maybe has some data it does an
analysis it releases a result and then
somebody gets a warrant and goes in and
looks at the internal state of the
algorithm so we want to be sure that the
internal State isn't revealing uh in
information about individuals even in
conjunction with what was produced as
outputs and um okay and the third
issue is what we called uh continual
observation so
um uh we might be doing something with
longitudinal data which can change
during every time period for example
um we might be continually reporting
things like users who viewed this item
also liked some other item
um and this was a real example that
happened
it's a very
a very generic sort of first item so it
was really interesting who actually
looked at that first item in the story
alone anyway but um or a daily report of
the number of tests or covid cases by
county or maybe cholera cases by
individual Wells
um or a total number of app downloads
during some time periods one through t
this is now the algorithm is continually
reporting sort of cumulatively what has
happened
um which is more challenging than just
doing some processing and outputting one
single output
okay
so I want to focus first on continual
observation
um maybe this is a variant of Russell's
question how many of us are present
versus how many of us have shown up
um so I want the approximate total count
I.E prefix sum at every time step
um how many people have shown up so far
so one thing that we could do let's
assume just for Simplicity that
at each step only zero or one people
show up just for this particular slide
in this point we could use say
randomized response or LaPlace noise at
each step and if we do that and we run
for some capital T number of steps the
arrow will look something like square
root of T over Epsilon where Epsilon is
our privacy parameter
but instead it's natural to use an
um a tree based counter which gives us
event level privacy so I'm focusing on
event level privacy
and I'm going to be sort of pounding on
this one particular story but there is
or example but there is a serious payoff
that comes at the end
so here we have a non-private tree based
counter
um you could uh it's a complete binary
tree and the nodes are labeled starting
at zero and ending up at T in binary I
interrupt with a question
yes G minus one
so in your picture you had like things
Mark yellow and blue and these are
different events
sorry in the yellow cells somebody
showed up let's say and in the green
cells time periods nobody showed up oh
okay but so you're looking at like event
level
um are the different kinds of events
what counts as an event what are related
is that known to the algorithm or we
have to worry about arbitrary
no no these are very
kinds of events that you're counting
like again how many
people okay thanks
okay so
um
good so a non-private tree based counter
uh you could imagine something like this
I'm I've got
uh some power of two and I'm labeling
the nodes the leads from zero to uh two
to the T minus one and we could put the
data at the leaves and we could put the
subtree count at the internal nodes and
certainly from something like this it's
very easy to figure out
um for any prefix how many people uh
what what the prefix sums are
um so for a prefix of linked Little T
less than T right Little T in binary and
follow the following algorithm I'm
writing T in binary is uh B1 B2 up to B
log T so if bi is equal to zero we just
move left and do nothing so here in my
example T is three and I'm I want the
sum of the first three so this is zero
one one
um I move left
and because it's a zero um but I don't
do anything and then if the next bit is
a one I'm going to move right and I'm
going to add the prefix sum at the left
child of the node before I make that
move
and then there's another one so I do
exactly the same thing and that gives me
the count in the first three cells the
sum of those two guys okay and special
case for the root um if I want all
capital T I have to read from the root
so not not complicated uh tree based
counter
um
and of course all of my prefix sums are
now expressed by the sum of that most
log of capital T number of values
the differentially private tree-based
counter looks very similar only I have
uh noisy counts noisy data at the leaves
and a noisy uh internal nodes and the
noise is drawn from the LaPlace
distribution with parameter one plus log
T
capturing the fact that an individual
can affect the data at one plus log of t
uh many nodes
um good it's a variant on this
um it's a differentially again a
differentially private tree based
counter but I'm not going to be storing
a lot of stuff internally I'm going to
just
publish prefixes as I get them and and
allow users to take published data and
put stuff together so all I need to do
is say what do I need to publish so
initially I'm going to initialize all of
the nodes internally well all the nodes
sorry in the in the in the tree with
independent noise independent draws from
this LaPlace distribution and I'm going
to initialize the count to zero and at
each time step T I will add to the count
x sub T minus 1 because remember I've
named these guys this is the first guy
but
it's labeled T minus one it's labeled
zero okay and then I output
um when I want to Output say this thing
I output the value uh the count so far
plus the sum of the noises that I
created at all of these levels
so mathematically it's very similar to
what we did before
um
but it uh it's not going to be pan
private so the first thing we want to do
is we're going to shrink it so this is
small continual output differentially
private tree based counter and the idea
here is just like before only when we've
completed a subtree we just prune it we
get it we delete it from memory
and we don't create nodes in this tree
until we actually need them so the
functionally they work as before but we
don't create we only keep a sort of a
log sized uh object working at any time
and it turns out that this is pan
private so not only is it differentially
private under continual observation but
because of the way we've handled the
noise it's also pan private
um if somebody were able to break in and
see what's going on in the internal
nodes even then privacy would be
maintained
okay
now
um
we don't actually need pen privacy for
the rest of this talk although I'll
mention it once more at the end but
we're going to be interested in this
algorithm again uh because it has
um this special property that I'm
writing here in blue that all of the
outputs are sort of the true counts at
this time plus the sum of one plus log
of T identically distributed random
variables
so one of the things that they did in
this paper was we said
we're going to give you an example of
doing something non-trivial with a
counter or
um with it with prefix sums
so we looked at the online learning
algorithm of follow the perturbed Leader
by kalayan dampala I think it's 2005.
and what we want to do is we wanted to
keep private the experts
recommendations at any individual step
so
um uh
so the what the the intuition so this is
the original algorithm the non-private
algorithm we have some K number of
experts for each expert we choose a
weight at time t with uh according to an
exponential distribution and then
letting C sub T at I denote the total
cost or regret sort of so far for that
one particular uh expert
we compute the cost minus this perturbed
random value and we choose the argument
I of this difference okay so that's the
kalayan dampala algorithm
now what we did was
we sort of observed that the only thing
that mattered was the total cost so far
for this particular
um uh expert so for each expert we only
need its total cost so far
so we said okay let's maintain an
approximate cost so far using this
differentially private under continual
observation tree
um uh output algorithm
now we know that the quality of our
outputs are going to be pretty good that
is the differentially private
approximation is going to be pretty
close to the truth
but we actually didn't we don't know
maybe somebody else knows by now but we
certainly didn't know how to argue
um uh success for our algorithm based
solely on the approximation error
however
um fix a particular expert and let y sub
T be the cost incurred by this expert at
time t
plus the noise that we would get in the
approximation
plus any of the randomness in the follow
the perturbed leader algorithm that is
in particular here in step one of that
algorithm
so remember at each step the noise in
the approximation is the sum of one plus
log of T independent draws from the
LaPlace distribution so we're using this
property now
um the expected sum over T of y t so the
cumulative expected the expected
cumulative cost is the sum of the
expected costs for for this particular
expert
which in expectation is the same as what
we would have gotten if we did our log 1
plus log T draws from the LaPlace added
them all together called that our one
round noise and added the same one round
noise at every step this is just a
thought experiment we're not saying to
do this but it's a thought experiment in
expectation these would be the same
so we would be looking at the X the sum
over T of the expected value over a
particular uh one set of one plus log T
independent draws from the LaPlace of
well the red stuff is the red stuff so
now we have the cost incurred at t plus
the randomness of this plus that that
red stuff okay
now
just like an insight into where we're
going we can view this sort of fixed
noise as an extra cost that happens in
some prefix it's not changing round to
round so it's as if we had been running
the follow the perturbed leader
algorithm and incurred some extra cost
in some prefix and now we can kind of
use the power of the um
uh of the Kalyan vampala argument
to argue that uh uh the overall regret
is small
okay
so
we started with these definitions of
privacy and privacy in the online case
and then we noticed that some learning
algorithms uh really only depend on
cumulative loss I mean they all know but
cumulative loss and we did something
sort of useful with that
so that notion was picked up on I think
for the first time in 2013 By smithorta
and they applied it
to on online convex optimization but um
and I'll get to that in a minute but
let's back up for a second
remember just your standard online
stochastic gradient descent so you have
your as inputs to the algorithm this is
not private just
just the usual stochastic gradient
descent
we have a convex set C in p-dimensional
space we have some step sizes 801 Ada
two and for the rest of this
thing I'll just make them all the same
and some initial point x naught in C
and in iteration T we let x t plus one
T minus
um
uh the
the learning rate times the gradient of
Ft at x t and we project all of that
down to C so
um and I'm going to call this gradient
GT
so GT is typically a loss that you would
say incur if you get a new data point d
sub t plus one and we're at location x t
okay uh did I say that I meant GT is the
gradient of that ft is that loss
okay
so that's just Standard Online
stochastic gradient descent
now
prefix sums
uh can play an important role and
they've turned out to be playing an
important role in online convex
optimization and uh private gradient
descent ining gradient descent in
general but the point is if you want to
do your online learning with privacy you
would want a differentially private
version so just to follow the perturbed
leader only cared about the cumulative
costs incurred by the experts online
convex optimization and stochastic
gradient descent only care about
cumulative sums of gradients so you can
see this by um in this inset comes from
aberdeep takurta you can deconstruct the
SGD model update so Theta t plus one
what I was calling X2 plus one in the
previous slide is Theta T minus the
learning rate times the gradient at time
T and that just by expanding Theta T is
Theta T minus one minus blah blah blah
which turns out to be when you unwind it
all the way your star starting point
minus the learning rate times the sum of
the gradients at all of the steps
so the Insight that Adam and Arbor deep
had in 2013 so 10 years ago was gee we
should we should keep track of these
cumulative gradient sums prefix sums
using the tree based method
and
it turns out that not only does that
work for stochastic gradient descent it
works for
um also on decks
um online convex optimization and in
particular Follow the regularized Leader
updates and
um
uh
so
what that tells us is that this
differentially private
method for keeping prefix sums is very
useful for differentially private
learning and that has suddenly become of
very very wide interest as industry kind
of moves Whole Hog into
um trying to do private trying to do
okay AI and machine learning but in
particular trying to add some privacy
so there are a number of options when
you want to try to get some kind of
privacy preserving stochastic gradient
descent you could do something very
naive which is perturbation say using
the Gauss or some other method at each
step
um for the for the gradients themselves
and that's a very expensive
computationally and doesn't give you the
best balance then you could
um uh do a really cool trick that
basilia Smith and sakurta came up with
which is randomly sample one point
and blow the effects of this one point
up by the size of your data set and
trade off the Privacy loss that you get
by what's called privacy amplification
by sub-sampling with the cost of uh
increased sensitivity that comes from
blowing things up so that's a
computational Improvement but not an
improvement on the privacy
then there are many batch algorithms
where the Privacy comes in part from sub
sampling from the privacy of the sub
sample at every step then
um because there are some concerns about
how do you do this uniform sub sampling
and how do you keep private in a really
large system where there isn't you can't
keep secret the fact that data are
moving around how would you have privacy
of the sub sample so they entered so
there's a whole notion of What's called
the shuffle model which is a different
form of computing
there are techniques in called
amplification via iteration that sort of
say hey we don't need every step to be
differentially private in the sense that
we don't need to see the outcome of
every step we can hide the journey all
we care about is where we get at the end
of the learning process
and if I understood the literature there
are some similar issues about
um that the mini batch and shot that the
mini batch model has
uh at least according to a paper by
Kairus at all
um and then there are the prefix sums of
the gradients which then will avoid a
lot of these would which seem to avoid
these issues
so
last year
Google announced that in the um uh
gboard
for European Spanish next word
prediction
they train the model of
production model using this a private
tree
um and uh here's what they said about it
this is the first uh production neural
network trained directly on user data
that has this formal differentially
private guarantee and we don't have time
to go into it but it satisfies some form
of um uh zero concentrated differential
privacy
so in my last slide
um
the paper on pan privacy has several
proofs
several lower boundaries and
impossibility results
and and
um today's question is
where did Tony write one of these lower
bound proofs
so
to say that she wrote it on 101
which is true she wasn't in a building
near Route 101 she was actually on Route
and she was driving at the time
and that's my embarrassing story about
Tony
[Music]
um
thank you so much uh here are some of
the things that we did together we did
Pan privacy privacy under continual
observation we wrote the fairness
through awareness paper together with
Rich and others um which which sort of
launched the theoretical study of
algorithmic fairness
we did work on learning Fair
representations which has taken on its
own life
um and we worked together on uh showing
that differential privacy and some other
um other techniques that leak little
information uh protect analyzes against
um uh data dredging and and
um data exploration issues
so thank you Tony for your Brilliance
for your work for your collaboration and
for uh for being my very dear friend
it's amazing to see it there's a variety
of things that Tony had done you're
amazing Tony but you know
any questions any comments you could
speak up those microphones should pick
it up or I could give you the mic
and if people are online you're welcome
to speak up as well
thank you Cynthia it was a great talk
foreign
I don't know how many people understood
it but I thought it was really clear
okay yeah I think of someone just such
such a cool stuff
okay if there are no more questions and
you're welcome to login
[Applause]
and we have a 25 minutes break till 11
30 and then we'll recommend here for
even more talks from even more parts of
Tony's world but thank you so much
foreign